much madam chair as I know that running
late
I would only take a few minutes to say
first of all that most of the views that
were expressed on this points will
obviously guide our action in the coming
weeks and months and those of the next
Commission I'm sure be sure that what
happens in Shilla will always be at the
center of our attention because of the
ties that are there not only economic
ties but as I said social ties even
family ties it's a country that because
of history and culture is very close to
Europe and this is why we will continue
to be at the site of of Chile and this
delicate moment let me also concludes by
thanking the work that the Parliament
has been doing and is doing in its
relations with with Chile I want to
conclude with that in particular on on
Chile but also on other situations the
work that you do with the parliamentary
diplomacy is vital to the work of the
European Union diplomacy and I want to
thank you for that representing the
vibrant European democracy with a
variety of views it is extremely
important your engagement your constant
work with the parliaments around the
world but also with civil society human
rights activists and and the private
sector I believe this is an integral
part of our work and I would like to use
this opportunity to thank you also for
the work you're doing to keep the ties
between the European people and the
people in Chile through the
parliamentary diplomacy work thank you
very much thank you very much and so so
the debate is closed and we will move to
the next item on our agenda